Jacob would you comment on the mindset
that is being Advanced by Sam Harris in
this discussion of why it was a great
goddamn good thing that Twitter and
Facebook suppressed the hunter Biden
laptop story in the run-up to the 2020
election
so so my argument is that it was
appropriate for Twitter
and the heads of big Tech and journal
and the heads of journalistic
organizations to feel that they were in
the presence of something like a a once
in a lifetime moral emergency right
whereas this is not the same thing as
not liking George Bush
you know or not liking John McCain or
not liking Mitt Romney for their
politics this was here's a guy who
is capable of anything and we cannot
afford to have four more years with this
guy right and and so
um
so what what should
well-intentioned people do who have a
lot of power in these various ways you
know you're running the New York Times
you're running CNN you're running
Twitter
what should they've conspire to do what
do you do with the hunter Biden laptop
story
when we already know we know how this
played out in 2016 with the Hillary
Clinton email you know press conference
that was the killing blow to her
candidacy it's like a coin toss for me
the hunter Biden laptop thing because I
I do understand how
corrosive it is
for an institution like the the New York
Times to show obvious bias and
inconsistency and dishonesty in how they
because like they couldn't even frame it
honestly it's not like it's not like
it's like the way I would frame it is uh
listen I don't care what's in Hunter
Biden's I mean hunter Biden at that
point Hunter Biden literally could have
had the corpses of children in his
basement I would not have cared right
it's like there's nothing first of all
it's Hunter Biden right it's not it's
like it's not Joe Biden but even if Joe
like even whatever scope of Joe Biden's
corruption is like if you if we could
just go down that rabbit hole endlessly
and and understand that he's getting
kickbacks from Hunter and Biden's deals
in Ukraine or whatever else right or
China
it is
infinitesimal compared to the corruption
we know Trump is involved in
yeah well I listen I'm thankful uh
genuinely grateful to Sam Harris for um
he just he lines up so many
um corrupt and and
fallacious ideas in a row and I think
very usefully
and this is where you know I think he
does a real
um Public Service there is he usefully
shows the interrelation between these
various kinds of
um
fallacious and and I think destructive
thinking so to take this from the top
um here here's a person Sam Harris whose
whole career and reputation was built on
being a sort of human truth Optimizer
right his whole career was that he was
the dispassionate objective
the the the one who couldn't be swayed
by primitive and atavistic beliefs in
God or or you know an intrinsic uh moral
component in existence he was above all
of those things and what it means in
Practical terms to be above all of those
things
um is to be precisely the kind of
technocratic Judge of the good that
Harris makes himself here now not
everybody not every atheist takes this
as far as Harris does obviously but
um I do think that it is not an accident
that the that the same Sam Harris
who made his name as the great truth
engine is the the human truth machine is
now very flippantly saying it doesn't
matter what the truth is what matters is
the greater good which of course he is
in he is in the position to decide not
the American public or voters no Sam
Harris can tell you Sam Harris has
decided that it doesn't matter what's on
Hunter Biden's laptops it doesn't matter
that Twitter and Facebook censored and
repressed this what matters is that he
recognizes the grave danger of Donald
Trump so here we have a very important
connection which is the connection
between the kind of underlying let's
call it the the sort of metaphysical
layer of the technocratic mind which he
is a supreme representative of on the
one end and the oligarchic ruling party
certainty that it is in the best
position to decide whose votes should
count whose votes shouldn't count what
information can be seen what information
can't be seen
um so I don't think you you should look
at this and think ah Sam Harris great
truth secret Sam Harris as being a
hypocrite here I don't think it's
hypocrisy I think it's a cop to call
that hypocrisy no that is a perfectly
consistent position for Sam Harris to
take and this is you know what was the
Lenin call it like Imperial the highest
form of imperialism uh this is the
highest form of technocracy or the
highest form of the technocratic Mind
Sam Harris is the Supreme representative
of the technocratic minds and you know
it's also worth thinking about if this
was true if Trump was indeed the danger
that Sam Harris and others are
suggesting he was to Justified
everything why did they have to keep
lying about him I should say there are
many many reasons one could dislike
Donald Trump and could strenuously and
um you know vociferously object to his
presidency the difference between that
kind of political opposition and the
ruling party is twofold one it's the
degree of consensus across the the
ruling class and it's the use of the
federal agencies the use of the federal
bureaucracy in order to delegitimize an
elected president Donald Trump and the
way that this works where there is a
sort of
spontaneously emerging consensus bottom
up on the one hand which is the cultural
consensus among members of the ruling
class nobody needs to tell them Donald
Trump is uh is an ogre is an existential
threat they all feel this viscerally so
there's that element but that's met at
the same time by a top-down coordinated
effort across the agencies and we see
this with the FBI quite plainly we see
this with the uh people inside of the
FBI who are you know working on the
Trump investigation while exchanging
texts about how they're going to protect
democracy by keeping him from getting
elected we see this with the Jim Baker
who was the uh one of the lead councils
at the FBI leaving that job to then take
a job as a deputy lead council at
Twitter just in time so that when the
hunter laptop Hunter Biden laptop uh
story began to emerge he was in place as
the deputy council at Twitter so that he
could advise the company against uh you
know advise the company to go along with
the the you know requests uh mandates
essentially from the FBI that they not
publicize the story so that's the that
is the ruling party it is the success of
Donald Trump and these putative uh
populist elements that produces the
counter-reaction in the first place that
leads the ruling party to decide it can
no longer tolerate this degree of
autonomy and needs to clamp down and
effectively take control over the back
end of these platforms they they don't
do it uh they don't do it all at once
they don't simply nationalize the
industries as it or so it's always an
incomplete process and there's always a
space open for
these now sort of uh you know
unofficially
um uh illegal it's too strong but uh
unofficially blacklisted parties to
still find ways to prosper and there's
an argument to be made that the
technology tends to benefit them in a
kind of structural way but but this is
it's just the the sequencing is the only
the only place where I would disagree
with you so what I what I trace in the
in my essay and tablet is a chronology
in which first you have the open even
bombastic Embrace as of the internet as
a technology of Liberation and democracy
by people like Donald excuse me not
Donald Trump of course by people like
Hillary Clinton
um and uh Barack Obama who are touting
the benefits of social media in
particular as a force for
democratization across the world most
famously in the case of
um the Arab Spring but also with
protests in Iran
um and Clinton is the the head of the
internet Freedom agenda at the state
department you know one of her aides
famously Compares uh social media to Che
Guevara as a this revolutionary Force
you know very telling like the
platitudes they come up with here you
know
um so so it's these same people the very
same people who then declare the
internet uh the single greatest threat
to democracy what causes this utterly
dramatic 180 where they go from touting
the internet as a great force of
democratization to then declaring that
we we need to enforce martial law on the
internet lest civilization be destroyed
they perceive it as a threat to their
own power and uh continued mandate to
rule and it's as simple as that that was
reasons live stream with Jacob Siegel if
you liked it and want to hear the whole
thing go here if you want to listen to
another excerpt go here and come back
every Thursday at 1 pm eastern time for
Zach weismiller and I reason live stream